- We're doing well.
Say hello to GaryVee
and what are
your thoughts so far?
- Hey Joe.
- [DRock] What did the last
girl say on the radio show?
We couldn't hear it on my...
- The last call in from Joe
was, I was driving and Gary was
making me super uncomfortable
because he was
saying stop complaining
but I love complaining
and I live my life
complaining and it just hit me.
Joe, I love you so much.
You don't understand.
This is the
biggest thing for me.
Like, I've already
made my thing.
I'm gonna buy the New York Jets
and there'll be a movie and it's
gonna be great.
(group laughter)
At this point, Joe,
this phone call
means the world to me.
You have to
understand why this matters.
If you actually
believe what you just said,
if this is not a fleeting moment
of the energy of this show and
you're able to maintain that
feeling you cannot imagine how
much better your
life is going to be.
It's easy to complain.
Complaining is the easy way out.
Negativity is the easy way out.
You're lucky if you're gorgeous
but if you eat like crap and
don't take care of yourself
and do drugs and drink alcohol
you'll not look gorgeous.
You're lucky if you're 6'11"
and can sprint like a gazelle
but if you don't work on your
craft then you don't work on
your outside jumper, if you
don't work on your intensity and
your endurance you
won't be an NBA player.
So, yes, I got lucky that
I can win the game of life and
entrepreneurship but I've put in
the work for the last 25 years
minimumly and maybe even longer
to be the best version
of myself at this thing.
(light music)